So he's going to start in seon and I'm
going to do that atoshi move with the
choke. Okay.
So from here I'm going to come up
and down.
Same rule. Don't hit and give up the
center line.
Make contact.
Rotate the cross.
The weight of your body of your yong
aspect is what pushes that weight onto
that feet. Okay.
I'm here and it's
no not even close to bar dips. Bar dips
are hard. Farmer carries were hard.
Okay, got it. This I should be able to
relax. The more I relax, the more yawn
aspect will drop. The heavier the
technique will get and I'm not getting
tired. Okay, try.
You're going to watch with pure eyes.
You're already relaxed. Okay.
What stance am I in?
>> Okay.
>> How much gravitational barrier am I
using?
>> Okay, I'm just letting the young aspect
drop. It's enough.
Okay, so to help
I I'll do the maneuver
and I'll just You can see that I'm very
ready to keep moving forward. What do
you think will happen?
Now I got to do come up, shift weight
forward. Okay, so
I'm going to do my maneuver
and just walk forward. Okay,
>> go.
>> You feel the the press down. You see
what it does to him. Okay, but I'm just
standing here normal. Okay. It's no It's
no different
when you punch. I don't have to go here.
The the yong will drop and he'll feel
like
feel like that you felt heavier. You
felt like you wound up more. You see,
I'm just now putting it 3 4 feet away
from my body. But inside my body,
everything relaxes. Okay? And then that
force that's dropping down
drops everything down. Okay?
When we give you this task,
if I give you just the tush, that's
where we start seeing
that.
Now, I give you the quick transition
and we're not seeing the drop anymore.
Okay. Try it again. You got to get both.
So
the
the more I push down, let's say there is
weight of this on his feet of X, a value
of X. You got it?
>> When he tries to lift up, it's now X
plus Y because he's opposing the energy.
It will increase as an opposing energy.
you'll increase the pressure the value
at contact. You get that?
>> This is why
as I've said many times in the energy
when you're doing the energetics
when they resist the technique should
get easier because the adhesion value
went up the co value went up. Okay. If
you don't have the energetics then the
weapon he'll be able to overpower the
weapon. You see that? So for example in
those seated kokidosa
somebody who does not understand how to
use the qua right will get overridden do
it to your friends back home. Okay do
the spinal displacement and you'll see
what will happen. Okay but somebody who
does understand it you just made
yourself more projectable because the
energy value that they're working with
is now higher. Inversely,
on the first day, before you were used
to getting projected, we had to reel in
the yin the yin yield, remember? And
what was happening was the energy value
was dropping, which is why you did it.
You make yourself less. Okay? So, here
you don't want your hands
because your hands your like
mathematically. Yes. X goes up. But this
isn't this isn't math. This is
metacarpals to get it on wood. Do do you
understand? So whatever I I hit that
with boom. I I hit it now harder because
he's going up.
So marially I would pin him more. I
break his hands more. And I guaranteed
more of the ski because he got pinned
more. Okay.
What you'll see what he's doing is
there's ever so slightly a yielding to
the pressure.
You see, he is trying to absorb the
energy, not fight the energy. Okay? So,
when I'm coming in,
I can I feel the impact and I feel it go
because he's decreasing the value at
contact. Do you understand that? I won't
do it hard, but hold it up and you
you'll see tension go into the shoulders
and it pulls and it hurt it hurts the
hand.
Okay. But
>> but it doesn't make my weapon go up.
Make sense? Okay. So, two things.
You
don't let his resistance stop you. You
let it feed you. That was y it gets
internalized.
And then
absorb the energy.
Okay? So that we're not breaking hands
here. Make sense? Okay. Try again.